hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to perfection no not me not
my beautiful face
not my flawless skin perfection the game
this is a game about perfection
[Music]
I find yourself dreaming of something
better than the life you lead oh god yes
oh yeah to achieve that one now oh no I
want that one and this world starts with
you we're committed to perfecting
perfect to make your wildest dreams turn
into a reality so you can finally
realize your true potential
[Music]
I want it give a God demanded please
perfection in progress are you
perfection izing me I'm not perfect my
skin perfect all my eyes perfect
oh hello ah okay
well this this looks looks nice
[Music]
oh okay what is this me what am I
waiting for also I like how I kind of
slink in side to side Marquis mu boo oh
I'm a male which image makes you feel
the most uneasy
I mean well that guy can see me but I
can see him too and that's just like
finger and I the broken mirror that
probably suggests something more no no I
hope you enjoy the rest of your journey
to perfection okay well what do you what
are you doing with it what are you doing
with it
Oh oh my god I am already perfect
I know I am already perfect
you don't need to change me at all I'm
okay alright thank you
anyway let me get a good another good
look at me the me that I I have to say
goodbye to this astonishing beacon of a
man with my bald head my tiny ears my
slender nose my broad hands holy [ __ ]
look at my hands Frick okay alright wait
please enter Markheim Ubu EPA Yuri okay
alright can i oh hello
I'll take one heaping helping of perfect
please oh fiber symptoms of imperfection
my flaws that I always know that I have
important things for me and everyone
else and I tried hard to do it but I
never do and I consequence I disappoint
people I love to be perfect I would
change my attribute of laziness to
productivity I would never let down my
friends and family again okay
class good all right perfect music Oh
perfectly glaring light who's still in
secrets over there
can you hear that sounds like perfection
okay
perfect continue down the corridor okay
hi are you blind
whoa hi okay you were warned Marquis mu
Bowie plea err but whatever screw you
man okay whatever I don't need you why
be you when you can be perfect that's
what I've been saying my whole life
that's what I've been saying
good I could just need to be perfect
wait hang on there moves in that door
that said it wasn't in use what was in
that door yeah I gotta go back okay
little disturbing when you cut the music
like that makes me think that
something's gonna happen
so why was that lady crying in that room
and why's there no painting there
anything why is that hmm whatever I
guess I'll go in here there's a weird
yes don't look too good
procrastination depression anxiety to
get talents to have more kinesthetic
awareness for status respect money
friends love to be more competent to
unlock a great mystery what if the
mystery is within us okay
or what if you're I will do that how do
I do that do I just smash it on my
noggin I've got a real big head I don't
know who
oh [ __ ] hi Oh God Oh
Oh
maybe I shouldn't have put that thing on
my head was that perfect just the way I
was
so is it the lesson to be learned here
oh boy
oh good goody gumdrops some seems
different camp on my finger upon it hey
none of that what are you doing
why okay whatever you say
was that a pregnancy test someone
pregnant maybe okay are you worth it
well probably not considering wait a
minute let my nose in my mouth
Wow okay all right then
[Music]
excuse me I'm just gonna turn around it
excuse me whoa horn earrings
hey hey hey big stud hey are you doing
okay all right I don't know where I am
look at my little tushy go oh wait
could I back that ass up in the why were
you watching me hey that's a trick
question why do you think I was watching
you you were watching me hmm
okay whose blood is this what does it
matter it's just blood this is perfectly
normal blood sitting in a perfectly
normal place for blood oh hi wait wait
wait a minute
what hi what are you doing why was wife
who there was a painting there I saw I
saw right who is that who who are you
ninja not you okay oh hey how you doing
welcome back to the world okay
oh my field of view just got really
invigorated hello hello I'm here for my
perfection therapy okay anyway I'll just
go this way then thank you for caring
Oh No
I'm back here again why am i back here
again
oh it's darker that's always a good sign
Oh hmm something's different can I place
my finger upon it
oh well oh something's uh-oh wait wait a
minute wait wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute
wait wait wait wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute something changed
oh hey okay okay say more that Kido key
then you're gonna breathe have yes hello
you watch it will you do knock ah that's
that's bizarre
that's not right can I look at you again
can I stare deeply longingly into your
eye you know they say the eyes are the
window of the soul what does that mean
when it's on a door your eyes the door
to my heart or whatever how are you
doing
all right cool you okay okay oh you
disappear a knack to you okay all right
how about you hey friend how you doing
all are you looking good you're looking
good you're looking better now okay
you're looking good great
hello anybody anybody here gonna poke an
eyeball out at me okay here we go again
you can't let me go through this day
Hey oh hi hello how are you doing is
this another pregnancy test why would
this be left here I don't know you know
I don't know man
no no there's more blood how did this
get here see why perfection is necessary
hmm gas is used disgusting gross huh
hey wait a minute
I guess I don't need a look at those why
hey listen buddy look at how good
ah okay that's fine I'm not too worried
about that I think it's fine
well I can't move oh oh okay hey we just
swing wildly right here in the air okay
perfect me would have short black hair
instead of my shaved head I'd be slimmer
but still stocky I'd like to be more
confident in myself and be more tech
savvy all right well your wish is my
command I am getting out of here
never mind I'm not oh is that so
oh yes you say through the door of the
ominous music you say well away I shall
go but we all shall go
oh okay alright then I'll ignore hi hey
buddy I'm coming for you here comes a
tickle fight goochy goochy back at you
no oh hi oh well that's Oh patient mark
EMU Bowie plie or imperfection to target
physical appearance must extract beauty
from confidence within aa characteristic
synopsis is patient cancer curious about
their environment their curiosity makes
them hyper aware of their surroundings
participation follow orders no they made
their own decisions no matter the risk
patient reaction when faced with danger
they showed promising sizes of bravery
okay system error patient remains
imperfect Oh what wait wait a minute
wait but well you said make me perfect
patient remains imperfect but I don't
want to be perfect I guess I'll never be
perfect then no don't close the game
wait I gotta go back make me perfect
make me perfect I'll follow your rules
they'll do exactly as you say
oh boy here I go again but what happened
to my perfection what happened to the
possibility that I was going to be
perfect everybody out there wants to be
/ you you ought to be perfect right we
all want to be perfect I can't live with
my disgusting self I think there is like
a deeper message in this by the way just
to go on a more serious note okay my
name is Mark
Oh Fishbach
Fishbach that's me I am
okay let's say this one what about this
one okay or I'm gonna do exactly as you
say I'm gonna do exactly as you say
and I ain't gonna do nothing wrong hello
you're not smiling you were smiling
before you are not smiling I don't you
are not smiling either you guys oh
you're not you're not smiling either
okay what the [ __ ] I see something I see
something I don't know you know some new
that'd be nice okay shut up I'm putting
on my head my back my [ __ ] and my crack
okay hey okay I'm going for it you still
don't look happy
okay you are unhappy hey buddy
oh yeah you want a sassy walk you want
to say I don't know man why aren't you
happy what are you happy be happy damn
it why are you unhappy be happy damn it
your big perfect you're perfect just the
way you are that's the moral of the
story you're all perfect just the way
you are
oh boy okay
oh you're gone though that's just as
good that's doubly good no why are the
canvases blank what happened okay
alright nomatter hello hi oh [ __ ]
okay well I'm out of here
I guess all right okay if you say so
okay hello coming for you won't you go
to Gucci oh [ __ ] okay oh it's gonna be
perpetual running okay fear of being
alone endorse dopamine receptors without
needing for external stimulants
curiosity makes them hyper aware they
made their own decisions promise decides
of bravery patient remains imperfect
will restart would you dar i well i'ma
do imma be I'm obese I'm gonna be the
goodest boy shut up shut up okay here we
go again this time I'm not gonna screw
it up I'm gonna do exactly as I should
do I'm gonna go straight to the end of
the tunnel I'll be fine here we go all
right here we go okay we're going for it
all right I'm out of here baby oh please
be patient okay look at my sassy walk
you got it baby here I go straight to my
room no other distractions Boop okay all
right I'm a curious little baby I'm
soaked oh that's not that's that's not
right that's not right that's okay he
said he said okay that's not right I'm
not right here I don't like the eyes
okay good great here we go
goody goody goody good yeah good I got a
bad feeling about this please just let
me let me be perfect I just want to be
perfect just for a little bit please let
me be perfect oh I'm gonna be perfect
perfect perfect like a perfect baby
perfect baby no don't look at me don't
look at me
nope not gonna do it not doing it not
doing it not doing it not doing it not
doing it not looking at anything
now we're gonna anything especially you
guys are not gonna be looking at me yet
all right cool great now to hear baby
hey Bobo well screw that [ __ ] I'm outta
here
yeah okay whoa wait did that just what
we can almost open that what the [ __ ]
well weird weird weird okay whatever hi
what's not okay can I go back ha [ __ ]
you can I go back okay I can't go back
that's fine I don't care I don't care
I'm just gonna go hug you oh [ __ ]
hi hey how you doing okay alright fear
of judgement self-worth must be enlarged
and and not rely on other attributes
proved somewhat curious but remain
focused yes it will obey over taking
risks they're fearful of the truth oh oh
[ __ ] is there is there any other is
there any other thing to do about this I
guess at the end of the day the only
thing you can do is run an imperfect oh
well I guess we have to just accept the
flaws that we have inside of our souls
because really the beauty is only
skin-deep they say but in truth the
perception of the beauty is much deeper
than that
to access the inner workings of our own
mind and accept our own perfections
because we are perfect in just the way
we are without needing any sort of false
gratification for our own perfect
systems the ones we hold inside our
heart the image of ourselves that we
look in the mirror the one person that
we are that's what we have to accept at
the end of the day I don't know what I'm
talking about here so that is perfection
I think we all learn something today
perfection lies in here not in here in
here not in here in here not in here
I think we all know what I'm talking
about there so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to be
perfect for yourself I'll leave a link
to the game in the description below
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]